[Music]
whereís oh my goodness gravy
[Music]
what what's happening pinky's
challenging us to a we're gonna need a
bigger slingshot
Fred we've discovered a third island we
need to put aside our differences and
work together save world from being
destroyed what we really need is a hero
actually that positions been filled
she's super smart wait who's that and
why is she all over these achievement
award I just don't think this is gonna
work okay so what I'm usually angry walk
to herself
left-handed probably with fun being
alone okay guys
step one travel undetected to the island
pull the gadgets you'll see here have
been designed with your current mission
in mind the first Bing and visit spray
how long does the invisibility last for
forever
Tina we're not gonna be able to see each
other working with what we get
[Music]
we're gonna need a disguise
goodness crazy what's going on down
there
[Music]
pinkies challenging is 12
[Music]
oh it's on Wow - I don't know if I'm
gonna fit in your back anyone smell
bacon
[Music]